[Music]
welcome back to our next episode of
what's up prof hello walter
good morning how are you doing i'm well
and you this is a new year yeah yes well
happy new year to you i don't know what
is gonna
it's gonna be exciting but how happy
it's gonna be i don't know
i'll open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father
we are living in very serious times and
we
can only
bear through this if you help us we ask
you to bless us in this
discussion and also enlighten our minds
in jesus name amen amen
so maybe i'd just like to
put a disclaimer
when for
when we start this it might become a
lengthy
discussion and we don't want to split
this one and two no so
so why don't we speak at double speed
[Laughter]
yeah so there's a few options for the
viewers they can watch it at double
speed or they can either all
they can also
pause it and watch it later or continue
but we don't want to split this one up
yes and maybe it doesn't
become so long after all we don't know
it's just four it depends how it goes
yes
it's a very provocative title to vax or
not to vax
but before we even go there
has a lot of potential doesn't it yes
and it started off
with uh
with a bang
and we've just had major riots at the
capitol building
where the decision is to be felt whether
the next president is going to be the
old president or the new president
and people have been shot and it's uh
it's it's a very serious issue that is
going on
and mike pence
has been put into the firing line
and i'm sure some parties are pleased
and some parties are not so pleased
but
fortunately
we are
prophecy
people and we are looking at this
not from
the standpoint of a party affiliation we
are looking at the prophetic picture
so this is very fascinating
and then the elections in georgia
whether
they were rigged or whether they were
not rigged why did the power go off when
trump was in the lead and then come back
on when he was no longer in the lead and
oh there are so many stories out there
and so much anger yeah and frustration
so that's the one side of the story
and then of course
mixed into this story
is this great divide
where people are saying
our hopes are centered in trump for the
draining of the swamp
and the other side is saying there is no
swamp
there's only a
a global
village
so it's it's fascinating to watch how
this unfolds
so let's see where prophecy leads us and
then we have a few other things that are
happening this year
which are exceedingly significant
in terms of the prophetic
picture yes and that is
that in march as we discussed before
there will be
the celebration of the giving of the
sunday law or by constantine yeah the
thousand seven year jubilee the jubilee
that you know they love jubilees these
people and they always work in these
jubilee cycles
and uh they will be celebrating this and
trade unions will be involved and they
will be saying we want this legislation
to be
reinstated
and then the economical council
the healing of the wound between
catholicism and protestantism
and also in this year in april
will be the commemoration again the
500th year
of the ex-communication of martin luther
and
what can we expect from that event
i am
waiting with anticipation
is pope francis going to reverse the
excommunication to heal the wound
as some of these protestant leaders
and some of the lutheran leaders
especially from the scandinavian
countries
that are very lutheran have said that
the roman church is the mother church
the mother church
is the wound going to be healed in this
year
and can we see
exciting events
well exciting definitely
and in the mix
you have a pandemic
and there's a health crisis in the world
and there is a solution to the health
crisis
depending on which side of the fence you
are sitting in this issue right
and the vaccinations have become part of
this deal
and some people say
this is a plot by the swamp
and some people are saying no this is a
real issue that has to be addressed
so we have
two views clashing yeah
and it's sort of a mirror of what's
happening at the at the
at the capitol at the moment yeah at
every level actually it's just the same
mirror yes you've got these two
opposites in everything we've got two
sides that are in
absolute violent conflict
and now you have to choose sides
and who's going to take
which side
and that's what we're talking about here
so it's not just a question of to wax or
not to wax
it is a much deeper issue
finally
it will determine
the direction in which your mind will be
channeled
so let us talk about some of these
issues
and see what this year brings
now we're still going to talk about the
prophetic issues yes
later
but this is pivotal for the moment
correct
and people have already chosen sides
and
the rhetoric is
is powerful
even violent in some cases yes
to the point where people say that if
you do not see it this way or that way
you need to be exterminated yeah right
yeah yes yes you're a danger to society
they've said if you are an anti-vaxxer
then basically you are a murderer yes
yes you should be
you should be
prosecuted for murder or manslaughter i
mean this is how far this issue has gone
so it's very very important
to see
what is what is
brewing
fine so shall we jump right into it
please
to wax or not to wax
well i think it was in
2019 already
boris johnson
had a speech at the united nations
where he was talking about some of this
new technology and science
and how important this new technology
and science is to humanity
and
we have to compare some of these things
just to put it into context so let's
just listen to what he had to say
before
the epidemic
and there are today people who are still
actually anti-science
a whole movement
called the anti-vaxxers
who refuse to acknowledge the evidence
that vaccinations have eradicated
smallpox and who by their prejudices are
actually endangering the very children
they want to protect
and i totally reject this
anti-scientific pessimism i'm profoundly
optimistic
about the ability of new technology to
serve as a liberator and to remake the
world wondrously and benignly indeed in
countless respects technology is already
doing just that nanotechnology i
mentioned earlier
revolutionizing medicine by designing
robert robots a fraction of the size of
a red blood cell capable of swimming
through our bodies dispensing medicine
and attacking malignant cells like some
star wars armada neural interface
technology is producing a new generation
of cochlear implants allowing the gift
of hearing to people who would not
otherwise not be able to hear the voices
of their own children a london
technology company has worked out how to
help the blind to navigate more freely
with nothing more than an app on their
smartphones new technologies produced in
britain helping the deaf to hear and the
blind to see and we used to think that
printing was something that you did to
run off a boarding card now a british
company has used 3d printing to make an
engine capable
of blasting a rocket in space in african
countries millions of people without
bank accounts can now transfer money
using a simple app they can buy solar
energy and leap in one transaction from
no electricity to green power and new
advances are making renewable energy
ever cheaper aiding our common struggle
against climate change our understanding
of the natural world is being
transformed by genome sequencing the
discovery of the very essence of life
itself the secret genetic code that
animates the spirit of every living
being and allows medical breakthroughs
the like of which we have never known
treatments tailored to the precise
genetic makeup of the individual so far
we have discovered the secrets of less
than 0.3
of complex life on the planet think what
will we achieve what we will achieve
when and it is a matter of when
we understand one or two percent
let alone five or ten percent
but how
how we design
the emerging technologies behind these
breakthroughs and what values inform
their design
will shape the future of humanity and
that is
my point to you tonight my friends
that was a mouthful yeah
so
already before
the pandemic he was
referring to anti-vaxxers
and he was condemning them in no
uncertain terms yes
not only that he
told us about technology
where you have robots smaller than the
size of a
red blood corpuscle
coursing through your body delivering
medication to the precise loki where it
is necessary
and then he talked about a.i and all
these marvelous interface
inventions that are there and the great
wonderful future for humanity
now
martin
does that
gel with what the bible is saying about
the future of humanity
no
if i read the bible correctly it says
that everything will be going down
and we will be having some chaos yes
now
you know what i i'm a scientist
and i love science i've always loved
science
there's nothing wrong with science
science is a beautiful tool
that enables us to understand nature
but if science is not in harmony with
the word of god then it is a false
science yes
and the philosophy behind it
is then a very dangerous philosophy
because it leads you away from the truth
and not towards the truth
rightly understood science must be in
harmony with god's word yeah correct 100
now that is quite the divide especially
in the evolutionary world and what have
you
but the technology is available
to
absolutely
use
nanotechnology
micro robots to
do all kinds of things
now
technology
is it always
a case that it is being used for good no
unfortunately that's where the problem
comes in so if you if you discover
nuclear technology
and you can power the whole world and
give everybody electricity that's
marvelous yes but could you use that
same power to obliterate humanity yes
i see
so it all depends
in whose hands this power
is lodged right correct
and
do you always know whom you can trust in
this kind of scenario no
and unfortunately i think we can go as
far as to say
as long as it stays in humanity's
hands
it's dangerous
correct
now this was not all that he was talking
about in that speech he also in that
speech spoke about how this technology
can be used
to control
right
now we won't be dealing with that in
this in this lecture we'll put that into
a future lecture
but there is the issue of the power and
the technology and then there is the
issue of the control yes how you can use
it to control humanity yeah he actually
in the speech
that we'll be using in the next one
refers to how it can be used for good or
for bad exactly let us just read a quote
from the spirit of prophecy the lord
desires his church to be a perfect body
not all arms not all body without arms
but body and arms together every member
working as one great whole
as the right arm is connected with the
body so the health reform and medical
missionary work is connected with the
third angel's message
and is to work efficiently as the right
arm for the defense of the body of truth
so there is a health message
which has to work together
with the truth yes
is it possible that there is an
alternative health message that can work
on the other side
the devil always copies what the lord
has given so does he have a right arm to
his message i believe yes and did boris
just tell us
that
this medical breakthrough that we are
seeing in the world
is the way to go
the medical world is going to decide how
you should run your body yes is that
correct
now does the medical world
have problems with
naturopathy
yes yes and no
there are many that say okay we have to
go the natural route but when it comes
down to the line
then
the medical route the allopathic route
is the method of choice
now we've had this discussion before
there are these three approaches right
you have allopathy
fighting
fire with water yeah
you have homeopathy fighting fire with
fire and then you have naturopathy
giving your body everything that it
needs to cope with the issue by itself
in fact
nobody can really heal you the body has
built-in mechanisms to heal itself yeah
you can enhance
the mechanism of healing or create the
circumstances for the body to heal
itself you've just had a shoulder
operation
right
that's why your arms are
i'm so sitting so still
so this is not normal but
but uh
they've actually
put muscles into their right place again
etc
but did they heal you instantly or did
they create the circumstances for your
body to heal it yes the body has to heal
itself exactly so all of these medical
issues have their place so the natural
way
naturopathy
should in my opinion
be your first choice
then you must decide after that whether
you want to go the allopathy way or the
homeopathy way we're not going to go
into the issue
if you
if you have a bug that is going to kill
you
then it would be wise to kill the bug
before it kills you that's where things
like antibiotics come in that's
allopathy right
so that is fine and
we can
use the medical world
when it is
rightly understood and does not come
into conflict
with god's
word and god's natural ways
so let's have a look at this issue
of covet 19. and
there's there's so much division in the
world
so we'll have to be very careful how we
state this right martin we just state
what's going on there and then people
can exactly
so here's times now news researchers
introduced the first artificial
intelligence tool to detect covert 19
probability
so here's this research company that has
developed ai covert software
so here we're talking about this
union between technology
and
the medical world
nine months into the pandemic we now
have a better understanding of how to
care for patients with covert 19 but
there's still a big bottleneck in covet
19 diagnosis
with pcr testing so this team believes
that a secondary benefit of laboratories
incorporating a i covet might be reduced
time for traditional pcr results
so there's no doubt that
technology and medicine
are merging
in the time that we are living in
so is it possible
to introduce medicine and technology
simultaneously yes
definitely it's definitely possible
right and depending on whether you trust
the individuals that deliver it
you must make a decision whether you
will allow it or not right
correct you have to have a choice you
have to have a choice
now where lies this choice
with yourself are you sure well
unfortunately it's supposed to
or is it uh is it somebody that will
decide for you how you must choose
that's where we're reading this is what
this talk is about
this talk is about who
makes the choice
and we have to be
very clear on this issue
so here's an article from the washington
post smart pills with chips cameras and
robotic past raised legal and ethical
questions so already this technology is
being used yeah and it was this is from
2014. this is 2014. so here they had
smart pills and went into your stomach
and monitored what was going on there
and sent you a report on your computer
etc etc and this was still at a scale
which wouldn't be at the microscopic
scale
but as boris told us we're heading that
way yes
so
let's say that you could integrate a i
with this robotic system
or pre-loaded
nano robots
then you could target certain organs
could it be used for example to deliver
drugs that would calm you down yes
or
switch off your thinking capacity maybe
or your
whatever calm you know it's possible
right
depending on
who the intention who's doing it and
what the intention is
so
let's look at the vaccination issue
we've had a lot of propaganda
and many many articles from scientists
from religious organizations
from even the creation
organizations in this world
and they are taking their stand as to
which way we should go now here's an
article by robert carter
and it's from creation.com creation
ministries international
and he is speaking on behalf of the
vaccination
and he's talking about rna vaccines
harnessing god's design to help prevent
sickness
but will the new vaccine technology
alter our dna
now this is a creation scientist
could an rna vaccine alter your dna
even though the wild version of the
virus used in the astrazeneca vaccine
can also do this it is not known to
cause any diseases
even so the rna contains but one or two
protein coding genes
this is not enough information to do
anything in the cell
any cell
that takes up the foreign protein gene
will be killed by the immune system
at least that is what it is what's
supposed to happen and indeed is what
does happen in nearly all cases
he's very careful right
in nearly all cases
the immune system is
exceptionally complex and we cannot say
that every single person will respond in
the same way
but if this is a concern it should be a
concern for all viral infections as well
well two next ante has a point here
because viruses enter your body and
bring with it protein and dna and
messenger rna so
the vaccine will do the same thing
but the vaccine also has different
technology
which enables it to do things that
naturally might not be the case
the arms muscles are far from the gonads
so even if some cells incorporate the
rna in the form of dna into their
genomes
it will be difficult to pass this to the
next generation
again nobody can say it is impossible
but there is little reason for
considering it to be probable
then again we have sometimes been
surprised by biology
so he's saying
don't worry about it
it's possible but not probable
and we have a pandemic after all we need
to do something right
considering all these points together as
a scientist with a strong background in
genetics i believe the risk of the
genetic engineering of people is
extremely small
thus not sufficient to warrant halting
these vaccine trials
we can always be surprised but
everything we do know tells us that the
new technology should be safe
thus the goal is to study this new idea
until every significant concern has been
addressed after that we can proceed
cautiously while reassessing every
serious concern at each step
now
let me go back to boris
he said we know one percent two percent
but if we really get with it we might
know five percent right yes
how much is then lacking
yes between 98
and 95
exactly in other words will we ever
discover in its fullness the intricacies
of god's creation
we will be studying this for all
literally
isn't that correct correct
if i may
just comment on this last sentence
the problem that i just have is that
yes we can check out all of this and so
on
but who's it being checked out on
so after we can after that we can
proceed cautiously to look back on what
has happened and then address it but
unfortunately this you become the guinea
pig you the kidding pig so then we have
to look back in five years time and oh
shucks
there's a problem there all right
so you know i'm also a scientist and i
also have a background in genetics and i
used to be an evolutionist and now i am
a creationist
and this man is also
and he says
there is a very very small probability
that
it will be incorporated into your genome
so it's not genetic engineering you're
just using
the messenger rna but
it's not
like that in all cases yes you know what
if you consider what the evolutionary
scientists are saying
about how our genome came together in
the first place
then it is the exact opposite of what is
being said here
because
the idea is that
bacteria and viruses in the past came
into the body
and like mitochondria for example it is
assumed by the evolutionary world that
mitochondria
were
organisms of
not the body originally but became sort
of symbiotic creatures within you and
that there was an exchange of dna and
they still have their own dna but some
of it became incorporated into the body
and that's how your genome eventually
grew to what it is today
the dna to come from somewhere right
so in their evolutionary thinking
they're incorporating all of this into
your dna but now denying that it can be
incorporated in your dna this there's a
there's a problem there right
so the reality and the philosophy
are not gelling yes
so the philosophy is there because you
have to find a way
to explain how your genome grew to what
it was
and the only way to explain that is that
it was incorporated
but now when it comes to the vaccine you
have to say no it does not get
incorporated yeah because nobody wants
to become genetically modified exactly
so
this is a bit of an interesting
discussion but i'm not choosing sides
yet
that's why i mentioned it it's just
the statement that he made
if i look at it
logically and he says
this
is in all probability not a dangerous
thing yes but we can in the future look
back and see if there was a problem
exactly all right
so here is medcam medical lectures
explained clearly as the youtube channel
it talks about the pfizer and the
moderna
vaccines that use messenger rna
in their covert 19 vaccines this never
before used technology could transform
how science fights diseases
so let's have a look at what these
people have to say so that we can get
both sides of the story yes
now as you will recall the pfizer
biontech vaccine and the moderna vaccine
are basically new vaccines in the sense
that they are injecting messenger rna
into your cells to tell the cells to
produce the protein that is the same as
a portion of the spike protein on the
virus and that is what generates the
immune response so in other words we're
giving instructions to the cell to make
the form protein which causes the immune
response and that is actually very
similar to the astrazeneca oxford
vaccine except instead of using
messenger rna they are using dna to do
that
so once again in terms of a picture
imagine we have the cell and we've got
the nucleus
and what we were doing before was we
were taking messenger rna
and that messenger rna was being
translated by ribosomes and converted
into
the protein and what we did with the
pfizer biontech vaccine and the moderna
vaccine is we were getting the messenger
rna into the cytoplasm of the cell the
cytoplasm is the outside portion
as opposed to the nucleus
how do we get that messenger rna in the
pfizer biontech vaccine and the moderna
vaccine in well we used a lipid bilayer
or a micelle as we called it to get
those fragments or that messenger rna
into the cytoplasm and then from there
it's fairly straightforward the cell
uses its own cell machinery which is the
ribosomes to cause translation to occur
and you make the protein in question
how this is different is astrazeneca
uses a different technique and it uses
a virus called an adenovirus
but not a human one but a chimpanzee
now the adenovirus here does not use rna
like we've been talking about it uses
dna and dna is a double stranded form of
instructions now there's a portion there
in the middle of that that is used for
replication of the virus well the
genetic engineers simply delete that
portion so the virus can no longer
replicate and cause an infection in the
human body and instead they replace that
portion of the dna with the genetic code
the instructions that the geneticists
have engineered and so what happens when
you deliver this adenovirus in the
vaccine it goes into the cell and it
releases the dna into the cytoplasm
and then that gets taken up and goes
into the nucleus
that dna
according to scientists at astrazeneca
does not get incorporated into the
host's genome it does not go into your
dna in the cell but rather it is
transcribed
into rna and that rna then exits the
nucleus as a messenger rna and then
exactly the same thing happens as what
we saw with the pfizer biontech vaccine
and the moderna vaccine which is that
the messenger rna which is now a product
of the transcription of the dna gets
converted into the spike protein through
translation by the ribosomes and then
this goes on once again to cause the
immunogenic response
professor crotty the research from you
and your team that's been featured in
the new york times and has been recently
held up by dr fauci at a congressional
hearing has been key to our
understanding about how our immune
system reacts to this new coronavirus
mrna um does its work just in the
cytoplasm of our cells is that correct
that's correct so yeah i've gotten lots
of questions about well wait isn't this
genetic engineering i don't want to be
genetically engineered i'm like well
fair enough i don't want to be
genetically engineered either
but but this is rna it's just messages
they're
they're transient temporary they don't
become part of your body uh it's it's
just not the same thing as dna
now what about speaking of dna the
astrazeneca
vaccine candidate that that utilizes dna
so um and so both the astrazeneca
uh approach and the johnson and johnson
approach use um a viral vector um
and it is a viral vector that contains
dna but really it's it's about the virus
so they're they're using a different
virus and adenovirus as a delivery
system um into your cells essentially
you know sort of like giving you one
viral infection to teach your immune
system how to fight another violent
infection that's that's also transient
dna that doesn't become part of your dna
that's that's just the viruses dna and
those viral vectors they've been they've
been gutted um so that they can't
become another adenovirus it's it's
it's like taking a car
and taking out the engine you know and
even and taking out the seats um it
still looks like a car from the outside
and you can put some new stuff in it
and you're sort of showing that to the
immune system to teach you what
something looks like but it's not going
to go drive off on its own or anything
so according to the scientists
that dna is not incorporated into your
genome
now according to the evolutionary
scientists how did the genome increase
in the first place
by incorporation right so we have a
clash of philosophies here
so they're pretty sure it doesn't get
incorporated but that dna fraction goes
into the nucleus and is actually
transcribed
in other words it's going to make
messenger rna
which is going to go to the cytoplasm
going to join up with the ribosome and
going to be transcribed into a protein
and that protein
will then be transported to the outside
of the cell and there it will initiate
the immune response
because it will be recognized as a
foreign protein and your immune system
will take over
and
any cell that produces that will
eventually be destroyed
because that's how the immune system
works but you've got millions and
millions of millions of cells so you
know
sacrifice a few and
then that's fine
what's interesting
is that sometimes even
messenger rna
it can be
reverse transcribed
and then it can end up in your dna yes
well that's what
the aids virus does
there's a reverse transcription
and it works backwards and splices
itself in
and fragments of dna
can end up in your dna it is not
probable that it will work and
eventually it will be destroyed so
they're saying it's perfectly safe
but you are playing with a genetic
system
that could possibly
change you
and maybe just another interesting point
for me personally
the scientists
producing the vaccine says it's safe it
doesn't sell it so now that
is there going to be any other
scientists
that can check if that's true now this
is the whole point
in this debate there are two sides
we referred to the pro-trumpers and the
anti-trumpers right there are two sides
and they're
they're very passionate about what they
believe
the same here you have two sides and
they're very passionate about what they
believe now just like these scientists
that we've just watched or saying that
it's perfectly safe there are others
that say that it's not perfectly safe
now the media
are giving which one's preference yeah
the ones that says it's safe the ones
let's say that it's the ones that so
there is a there is a
a drive towards propagating one view as
opposed to another view
and then you have uh all the watchdogs
that will take down any video
that says the opposite
now that is a system of control that
worries me so what we're talking about
here is not whether you are pro-vax or
whether you are anti-vaxxed
it's the system of control that bothers
me it is
silencing the other side do you have the
right to make your own decision yes or
well must your decision be made for you
that's the question
okay let's continue
so here's a video and the speaker here
is dr dolores and she's using a paper
that was published a few years ago
immunization with sars coronavirus
vaccines leads to pulmonary
immunopathology
on challenge with the sash virus so
there are a number of authors
and she has a few things to say which
might interest us let's listen
the cytokine storm is
that um so this is well known in many of
the vaccinations so i would just give
you these are slides that i prepared for
the interviews i did in may
the cytokine storm is
that when you put rna
genes you know mrna
or
um vaccine
injected into your body
you bypass all of the natural immune
response which would build up an immune
response to prevent the vaccine actually
entering your body okay
so that suddenly the mrna from the the
virus gets into your body and it uses
the human machinery
in the cells to express the human
proteins
so that suddenly the virus has been
injected into your body and then your
immune system sees the virus in your
body
as something that should not be there
and it mounts an immune response
but the shocking thing is that normally
you're immune you can get rid of the
virus particles you know or you can do
it's a slow thing but when you inject it
this mrna why it's so deadly is that it
now has
goes into your genes and starts
expressing and it starts stimulating the
immune response from inside your body
and it literally
you can't get rid of it because the
source of the viral protein you now
become like a genetically modified
organism and your body is expressing
the virus protein and so you're you
slowly your immune system starts to try
and get rid of it but you're remounting
this super you know beautiful well
exquisite antibodies to get rid of it
but you never can because it's now part
of who you are it's integrated and we
now the people getting this will become
a genetically modified organism that
will be making a virus protein
as well as uh their own human ones so
then when you naturally come across with
say the corona
virus naturally or the rsv as these
children did
the virus you breathe it in and it goes
on to your you know your mucosal system
and your bronchi
and then normally you would just get rid
of those virus particles you'd mount an
immune response
but what it does is because
that
one or two viruses as you breathe in
will suddenly trigger an antibody
response which normally happens over two
weeks
but then suddenly the antibody response
will now activate and realize oh my this
viral protein is in every cell of my
body
so then the antibodies start attacking
your cells and your organs
all right so
now you have professor dolores cahill
who says that it does get spliced into
your dna
as we see many say it does not so it's a
question of
does it does it not
and as we have seen
the evolutionary scenario is that it had
to be spliced in but the reality is that
it's not spliced in yes
so they say so which is it it's a again
a question of choice right correct
but what she does say here which is
interesting
is that when you breathe in a virus
it goes to your lungs
and normally then there is this immune
response and your body eventually starts
getting rid of the problem
at that local level
when you inject the virus into your
bloodstream
you're not
actually following that root you are
putting it into the bloodstream and
taking it to every
cell in the body
where normally
it would not be the case
so now you have a response
in your whole body
now
let us see what other scientists are
saying about this issue
so here is a whole group of doctors
that are being um
well ostracized
and
their opinions are being criticized and
even ridiculed in the media
but there are a number of medical people
here that are very passionate about what
they believe so let's just have a brief
look and see what they have to say
hello this is a world freedom alliance
we are here in copenhagen and i've got
the honor to introduce the corps members
from all over the world
we are the great resist
and it's up to you and up to us to
choose the world that we want to
welcome to the world freedom alliance
our message to the world is
you get what you accept you have a
choice
let us lead the way we are the great
resist the world freedom alliance
we just had a huge victory we were i
went out with pots and pans for two
weeks and we manage in the first time
first
round to to defeat the law on forced
vaccinations we'll keep on fighting
until it's totally abolished
so come and join the rally saturday the
21st
or 12 o'clock
see you there
wake up denmark wake up world
so those are all medical doctors and
scientists
and they're very passionate about their
view right
so again we are reiterating that there
are two sides to the story and people
will have to make a choice
here's another article this is quite a
recent one it comes from the 26th of
december
2020 and this is wachenblick it's a it's
a german magazine
and it is quoting professor sukharet
bhakti
he's also very prominent in the
anti-vaxx
circles
so what does this man have to say
well he claims that there are horror
risks associated with the corona vaccine
so it's just another opinion
and he's talking about serious bodily
damage
now what are his reasons
well again
this vaccine he says is not like any
other vaccine
we've discussed that it's a
messenger rna or a dna one
and he says there will be side effects
which will be
very extreme
and now this is just an opinion
so what are the what are the side
effects that he's worried about he says
there is this danger of
autoimmune
disease
and his point is that the vaccine is
being taken to all parts of the body
and there could be a autoimmune response
now in these autoimmune responses
the body then attacks its own cells
and
destroys them well very simple example
is diabetes type one
where you have an auto immune disease
which attacks your own islets of lung
irons and you no longer produce insulin
and then you have that autoimmune
disease
now i'm not saying this is the same
thing
but he's saying it's a possibility
and can we guarantee that it's not a
possibility no
no
the people are saying the probability is
very low
but
can we guarantee that it's not a
possibility no so
this dying of the body cells
will
you know affect the whole body not just
one thing this could be the greatest
catastrophe of all times
if you ask for trouble you're going to
get trouble
so this is an opinion of a of a
very highly respected
scientist who of course will also be
censored by the media
he says this is not a inoculation
but a
genetic
engineering
and then he quotes that in china that
this
corona
inoculation has led to
many deaths
so he's referring to
some of the consequences
that are not being
mentioned in the media
here's an article from cnbc you can't
sue pfizer or modena if you have severe
covet vaccine side effects
the government likely won't compensate
you for damages either
if you experience severe side effects
after getting a covert vaccine lawyers
tell cnbc
there is basically no one to blame in a
u.s court of law the federal government
has granted companies like fisa and
moderna immunity from liability
if something unintentionally goes wrong
with their vaccines
now
between the two of us is this
problematic
definitely
i mean
this is a little red light that goes up
it's a little warning sign right yeah
if they are so sure that nothing will go
wrong then why not put your money where
math is
okay
here is a government web page
and it talks about anaphylaxis following
mrna covet 19 vaccine receipt
so this is an official source yeah it's
from the cdc it's from the cbc europe
now anaphylaxis what is that
that is a severe allergic response
okay
so what do their statistics tell us
anaphylaxis in uk following covet 19
vaccination december 8
2020 uk initiated vaccine vaccination
with pfizer bioentech covert 19 vaccine
december 9 uk authorities confirmed two
cases of anaphylaxis after vaccination
prescribing information for both pfizer
bio in tech and modena covered 19
vaccines contains information on
anaphylaxis
so you have severe allergic reactions
to any component of the vaccine is a
contraindication to vaccination
appropriate medical treatment used to
manage immediate allergic reactions must
be immediately available in the event of
an acute anaphylactic reaction
recurs following administration of the
vaccine so these are recommendations
now what were the actual results
registrants with recorded first dose so
from the december they started
giving the doses and by december 18 112
807 people had received the dose
health impact events there are two
little stars there
and it says there that
unable to perform normal daily
activities unable to work required care
from doctor or health care professionals
so these are people that had adverse
reactions
and then out of these numbers you can
see that they are increasing from 3 to
50 to 373 to over a thousand then to
out of 112.
in other words they had reactions that
totally disabled them yeah 2.7 percent
if you work it out yes
so that is that is
quite alarming
now they're talking about pregnancies
alright that's not really
relevant here but
it's interesting that they are admitting
that there are adverse reactions but you
know what this is short term
what these other doctors were saying is
one of the long
autoimmune responses yes and the bottom
line answer must be
we don't
know exactly and when it does happen
don't sue us
because you can't
sue us
so those are the risks involved
so
where must the decision be made
i will go along with this i will not go
along with this all right where is the
wolf
and where
is
the
the victim right
is the covet 19 going to kill me
so that i really have to take this
vaccine now
in order to survive
or what is my probability of surviving
the covet 19
and then
not having the worries about anything
that could happen
further down the line that's a question
right less questions
and obviously if there is something
that's going to kill you in 10 minutes
you want to have some medication within
5 minutes correct
isn't that correct yes so i'm not
against allopathy
so if people say well people of
prominence have used vaccines in the
past
that doesn't mean that they will
necessarily use vaccines
in the present right correct
you know it's like this argument that
says
jesus ate fish yes so why shouldn't i
eat fish
but what if down the line the fish is so
polluted that it's no longer fit for
human consumption the question would
then be would jesus say let's go ahead
and eat fish correct
i can't see it happening all right so we
cannot use people of prominence in the
past
to say that they took a vaccine have you
had a vaccine in your life yes so i've
had vaccines in my life
because these vaccines just initiated my
immune response
because it wasn't in any way using my
molecular machinery
at the at the genetic level to initiate
a response
so
well those are the questions we have to
ask ourselves sky's news australia
youtube channel has the following to say
university of queensland's potential
coronavirus vaccine with csl
has been abandoned after trial
participants returned false positive
hiv test results this was one of four
vaccines which the morrison government
had entered into a deal with and is a
blow to australia's potential pool of
vaccine options let's go live to
canberra now for some reaction with tom
connell tom good morning to you it's a
significant development
it is so this is reported this morning
from rob harrison newspapers this still
has been abruptly terminated the
timeline was this on monday
csl working with uq found this issue
they informed the government by thursday
national cabinet had abandoned the use
of the vaccine there were 200 trial
participants in this vaccine
several of them have returned false
positives that's important to stress
false positives for hiv and sources
according to this story are saying these
people are not actually at risk so how
has this happened well this vaccine
actually uses a small component derived
from hiv so it's able to
it's used in the vaccine it's not able
to infect people nor replicate in the
body what it is able to do is
start a response within the body that
can actually interfere the screening
process and so that means return a false
positive we don't know how long the
false positive so this was always warned
about so no risk and it was always a
possibility
again they used a portion of
that particular virus
and they're saying there's no risk now
that might be so
i they see that they then continued with
their their trials afterwards again
after that had been cleared up but i
have a question yeah the point is just
there are so many uncertainties right
okay i don't understand maybe you can
just explain to us
what does this false positive mean so
if i go to
if i test positive now for hiv how do
they know it's not positive
if they say it's a false positive well
these people were not positive for hiv
before the vaccine and were positive
after the vaccine so obviously it is as
a consequence of the vaccine but what if
you hadn't been tested either yeah then
it could have been
and for how long will you now pay this
positive for hiv
that is another question that has to be
resolved
now modern there's another issue
these vaccines have to come in a number
of doses
because it is a step process
a first vaccination will only give you a
partial immunity
and therefore you need a second one so
that you can come up to 95
immunity
and the question
is
which vaccine did you receive the first
time and which one are you going to
receive the second time so this is
another issue
that has come up so let's listen to what
sky news had to say on this issue
it's all quite confusing isn't it adele
because you get the pharmaceutical
companies saying you know there's plenty
of this there are no capacity issues
from our side and yet it feels like our
expectations are being managed that we
might reach some pinch points with the
availability of the vaccine
yeah conflicting reports
mixed messages and overall a confusing
picture is being painted here of a
seemingly
unclear strategy from the government on
this and now this
latest news that the uk government
appears to have quietly updated its
green book on vaccinations saying that
potentially
vaccines can be mixed as you say so that
anyone who is going for the second dose
if that
dose is not available the same as the
first dose that they had or their first
dose it's not known exactly what they
had then they will be able to mix
they'll be able to have a different
vaccine as their second dose now this
flies in the face of guidance given in
other countries such as the us which
states that the that vaccines
the different vaccines are not
interchangeable and they're stating
reasons of safety and efficacy because
they simply have not yet been evaluated
there's even a quote in the new york
times from a world-leading expert expert
in vaccines john moore from cornell
university who describes this
from the uk government is seemingly to
have abandoned science completely he
says that it seems like they're trying
to guess their way out of a mess in his
words and of course again it raises
questions over the decision to postpone
second doses for those who've already
had one dose their first dose of the
fisa vaccination the government stating
that they want to maximize as many
people as possible getting one dose of a
vaccine to give some level of protection
and we have this statement as you say
from public health england released
within the last hour
which
basically the beginning of it starts to
say that it does not recommend
um that
vaccines are interchangeable but at the
end it sort of paves the way for it this
is what it says
we do not recommend mixing the covid19
vaccines if your first dose is the fisa
vaccine you should not be given the
astrazeneca vaccine for your second dose
and vice versa this is where it changes
a little there may be extremely rare
occasions where the same vaccine is not
available or where it is not known what
the patient received every effort should
be made to give them the same vaccine
but where this is not available it is
better to give a second dose of another
vaccine than not at all so it does
appear to be paving the way in some
circumstances for vaccines to be mixed
and matched if you like and on top of
that we have that confusing picture as
you mentioned on the one hand the
government is saying that there could be
a vaccine shortage on the other we have
the drug companies saying that that's
simply not the case so whether or not
it's a vaccine supply issue whether or
not there are also other reasons such as
a workforce capacity or a mixture of
both of them
so if you have made a decision that you
do not want the dna one
but you will go with the mrna one
and you just get anyone
then
it's problematic
but let's leave it at that
now there have been many reports of
adverse reactions and
there have been reports of people dying
some saying they all died of natural
causes
as american authorities said they are
studying the case of a 32 year old
female doctor who was hospitalized after
receiving the fisa vaccine
the ignition diagnosis was in
cephalomyolitis
the health ministry said in a statement
released on friday night
and encephalomyelitis is an inflammation
of the brain and the spinal cord
now here again you have a reaction which
is
directly in your nervous system
and
that could be
quite a serious issue and the question
is
how did the vaccine affect the nervous
system
did it cross the blood brain barrier how
did it get into the nervous system how
did it target the nervous system
these are questions two here's another
one 240 israelis found with covert after
vaccination underscoring need for
vigilance
in other words
it doesn't immediately eliminate it it
takes time to do this
so they still tested positive for covet
even though they had the vaccination
and then we have another problem yes
and this is that this virus is
mutating at an incredible rate
and here is the africa report which says
that the vaccine won't work against
south africa coronavirus variant worry
uk scientists
so the new variant of covert
in south africa have caused renewed
global concern in recent weeks but the
uk scientists now fear that it is the
south african strain that causes the
greatest risk
as it may be impervious to the various
vaccines that have been developed
including those of pfizer and moderna
okay let's just think about this so
everybody's rushing to get vaccinated
and then
the virus makes a switch
and then everything is null and void
then you have to do this whole thing all
over again right
and people are saying that the new
variants are so much more contagious
but they haven't spread
at that alarming rate yet so how can you
precisely determine how contagious they
are
so there's a lot of hype yeah
and there's a lot of fear-mongering that
is going on
to get people to respond
john bell regis professor of medicine at
oxford university told times radio that
there was a big question mark over
whether vaccines would work on the south
african variant
and that it might take months or six
weeks to get a new vaccine
so it seems to me
that
people are in for a constant injection
run
that's what it seems like yeah correct
so if you in this case now have had that
first two shots yes you're gonna need
the new one as well for the new strain
now none of these vaccines this is pure
science none of the vaccines have these
nano-robots or anything of that nature
in them
so this is purely a medical issue
but it seems that you will need to be
updated
as the strains change
is there a possibility that other
technology could be introduced in
vaccines if it ends up in the hands of
people that
have other agendas
it's possible right definitely
i'm not saying it is happening but i'm
saying there is
a remote possibility that it could
happen yes
all right so there are also
vaccines that can be
given in another format so that it
actually leaves almost a bar code on
your hand
so that you can be scanned
and
then you are basically
branded like a product
correct uh are we products but that's
that's something that needs to be dealt
with in another conversation
it further continues with south africa's
trade union federation cosatu has
criticized the government for being
caught napping
on the vaccine rollout program
we are targeting a minimum of 67 percent
of the population to achieve herd
immunity
and the approach will be phased roll out
of the vaccine beginning with the most
vulnerable in our
population this question of herd
immunity
and
the trade unions being involved now we
know that trade unions will be involved
in end time issues right correct
so when you look at all of these things
you are looking at
issues that that gel with prophetic
scenarios
and this issue of herd immunity
people are saying
you must be
inoculated so that
a high percentage some people say at
least 75
of the population must be inoculated
before you have heard immunity
and you need others say only 10 to 15
percent
to re achieve this herd immunity so
there is no
no
consensus
on what the percentage is
now
if you've been inoculated
and you are now immune to the virus yes
am i a problem for you if i'm not even
not
vaccinated that's i how i understand it
then you're not a problem if you even if
you have the virus i'm now immune to it
okay so let's say you're traveling
around in the world and you're going to
an area
where there is a problem like yellow
fever or something like that
you become inoculated and then you
travel to that area you can actually get
a certificate which says that you are
now basically immune against this
disease and so now you're off you go
so if i understand correctly you don't
receive the vaccine to protect the
people where you're going to is to
protect you going there correct that's
how it normally works right
so
if this scenario is correct then
basically the country that you are going
to should all be inoculated to have him
have heard immunity so that you are safe
going there going there without taking
the
vaccine so if you are not inoculated
then they will say but you are a danger
to them but actually they are a danger
to you all right
so that debate is very strange
when you think about it if everybody
gets inoculated and some people choose
not to be inoculated then those that are
inoculated shouldn't worry about those
that are not inoculated right the risk
lies with them the risk lies with them
so again
it's a question of choice
now
will there be penalties if you don't
inoculate
the daily mail says public transport ban
for anti-vaxxers in france
people who fail to get a coveted 19
vaccination could be banned from using
public transport in france
so according to the text which will now
be submitted to parliament a negative
covert test or proof of preventive
treatment including the administration
of a vaccine could be required for
people to be granted access to transport
or to some locations as well as certain
activities
so now we're talking about penalties
here's another
article
those who don't get covet vaccine could
face restrictions ontario officials say
so it's not just frauds
so you won't
they won't be mandatory but those who
don't receive a shot could face
restrictions we're heading in that
direction
is that coercion
yes
glo worldwide worldwide
new york post de blasio urges new
yorkers to embrace covert 19 vaccine at
bronx church service
the devil may be in the details but he's
not
in the coming coronavirus vaccine a
bronx city councilman and mayor bill de
blasio said during a sunday church
service
vowing to show new yorkers the shot is
nothing to fear
i want to tell everyone you're not
getting the 666 in this vaccine okay
he continued invoking the biblical
number of the beast i want to tell you
straight up there is no 666 there's no
conspiracy i'll be the first one to get
it if i'm allowed to
so the churches are involved and there's
the sphere of 666. now
we know that the vaccine has got nothing
to do with 666.
but this number 666 is interesting right
it is the number of the bees yes
and there are three sixes
and babylon has three components
there's the dragon the beast and the
false prophet
and i wonder whether they collectively
have a number right correct
so
yes religion is involved in some way or
other
and my question is should religion be
allowed
to dictate to your individual
conscience no
okay
mail online kumar gets tough on go slow
new york vaccine rollout government
threatens a hundred thousand dollar
fines if hospitals do not use vaccine
allocations by the end of the week
so they're basically forcing the
institutions to get on with it and do
this
okay
i want needles in arms and i want it
done as quickly as possible
kumo said what's the rush the pandemic
now here is the jesuit magazine
and everybody knows that
when the jesuits involved are involved
my antenna go up yes
the history of the jesuit order is
enough to make
my antenna go up and should be enough to
make everybody's antenna go up
some americans are skeptical about
taking a covered vaccine could religious
leaders convince them
one group of people who could help
encourage vaccination is faith leaders
who have the ability to reach
communities that might otherwise be
skeptical
so now here
not only the government is using tactics
to force people in a direction
now the jesuits are asking the churches
of the world to do
the same yes
that makes my antenna go up
definitely
the vital role of religious leaders is
going to be the framing and meaning of
protecting
oneself and protecting others
it's going to be bigger and a similar
job
to the mosque challenge
while most americans appear willing to
get vaccinated against coving 19 there
is still resistance including from some
catholic leaders earlier this year
two catholic bishops published
misinformation about the origin of the
two vaccines created by pfizer and
modena claimed that catholics
should not take the vaccine because they
were created using fetal stem cells
acquired through abortion
that led to the u.s conference of
catholic bishops to distribute a memo to
all u.s bishops reiterating church
teaching around vaccines
and stating catholics should have no
moral qualms about using the two
vaccines in question
now we didn't even discuss
in this
discussion
whether fetal cells were used and what
the moralities of that issue we were
just looking at the basic science of
what actually happens when you take the
vaccine
so this is another issue which we don't
have to bring into this debate right now
no
this discussion is just showing you
you've got a choice you have a choice
that's all it's about
now in his christmas message pope
francis urges coronavirus vaccines for
all so the churches are on board right
they're saying you must take this
the vatican earlier this month said the
use of coronavirus vaccines is morally
acceptable even if some vaccines are
manufactured using cell lines from
aborted thesis
and their research and production
process i cannot place myself ahead of
others
letting the law of the marketplace and
patents take precedence of the law of
love and the health of humanity francis
said
i ask everyone government leaders
business international organizations to
foster cooperation and not
competition and to seek a solution for
everyone vaccines for all
especially for the most vulnerable and
needy of all regions of the planet
so he wants vaccines
for all
here ctv news pope criticizes people
going on holiday to flee covet 19
lockdowns he condemned on sunday people
who had gone abroad on holiday to escape
coronavirus lockdowns
saying they needed to show greater
awareness for the suffering of others
i guess we must all suffer the same
right
we don't know what 2021 will reserve for
us but what all of us can do together is
make a bit more of an effort to take
care of each other
there is the temptation to take care
only of our own interests he added
now basically where he's going he's
saying
that if you don't get vaccinated
you are a danger to others correct and
this is what we discussed a minute ago
yes
when you go to you know yeah so this is
exactly we're
heading
that you are a danger to the society
society if you don't get this
so yes america again the jesuit review a
new vatican document refusing to get
vaccinated can seriously jeopardize
public health
so the roman catholic church
is seriously pushing
vaccination
and it's not a matter of choice no
the document highlights the critical
role of vaccines to defeat the pandemic
not just for individual personal health
but to protect the health of all the
vatican said in the statement
accompanying the document
they are absolute experts on everything
these jesuits it's amazing i'm correct
pope francis established the covet 19
commission in april with the goal of
expressing the church's concern and love
due to the close interdependence between
personal and public health the
commission and the pontifical academy
warned that refusing to take the vaccine
may also constitute a risk to others
given the absence of an alternative
vaccine that is not either developed
from or tested on the results of a
voluntary abortion
the document emphasized that the
vaccines currently available are morally
acceptable and that moral objections one
may use to refuse vaccination on
non-binding
the document continues
archbishop vincenzo
paglia head of the pontifical academy
for life
said his office is working with the
commission to address the ethical issues
regarding the vaccines development and
distribution
the joint document reiterated the points
made december 21 by the congregation for
doctrine of the faith regarding the
moral implications of receiving covert
19 vaccines
that were developed or tested using cell
lines originating from aborted thesis
now let me just stop there
who is this congregation for the
doctrine of the faith
this is the organization
within the roman catholic church
that studies and determines
issues of doctrine that are binding
eventually if ratified
upon all
so there's a small organization
of their theologians who make the
decision whether something is moral or
not
and then ratified by the pope it becomes
binding
for all the church members correct
now such an organization
the previous pope before he became pope
singer
was the head of the congregation
for the doctrine and the faith
so there are churches that have small
bodies that make decisions for many
people and here is now a religious body
that is determining the ethics behind it
and the current one that
pope francis
appointed is a jesuit as well
yes
it also cited the congregation's 2008
instruction
dignitas personae which states that
grave reasons may be morally
proportionate to justify the use of such
biological material
the pontifical academy for life the
document said also has addressed the
issue of developing vaccines using
tissue from aborted fetuses so these are
now moral issues
within the church
but then it states the document quoted
pope francis who said in his christmas
message
that humanity could not allow the virus
of radical individualism
to get the better of us and make us
indifferent to the suffering of other
brothers and sisters
nor could it allow the law of the
marketplace and patents take precedence
of the law of love and the health of
humanity
so there are two issues
the papacy seeks control
over the marketplace
and over the individual correct
it has the right through its structures
to dictate to the individual what is
right and what is wrong
to be to make your own choices actually
if a virus is a virus it's a virus it
must be eradicated
thomas aquinas already said
that such a disease should be amputated
you see it should be amputated so the
virus of individualism
is a problem
to this structure the roman catholic
church it has always been a problem to
it and it always will be a problem
it excommunicated martin luther
as a virus to their system
and now that they have conquered
protestantism through the economical
movement
they will reunite and probably declare
him a non-virus
in the near future we will see what will
happen in this year this is as much a
religious war
as it is a medical issue
yes because now he says
no individualism no individual but what
we've seen in the previous articles the
way the governments are handling
the vaccine
you don't have a choice either you don't
have a choice
so that they're they're singing the tune
of the vatican
you know brother martin
this issue of control
is a very serious one
and it permeates all of humanity
here's a statement in testimonies to
ministers a strange thing has come into
our churches
men who are placed in position of
responsibility that they may be wise
helpers to their fellow workers
have come to suppose that they were set
as kings and rulers in the churches
to say to one brother do this to another
do that and to another be sure to labor
in such and such a way
there have been places where the workers
have been told that if they did not
follow the instructions of these men of
responsibility their pay from the
conference would be withheld
there's this possibility of the spirit
the spirit of the antichrist
to permeate
the whole system
we have to be so careful
in his labors
this comes from the
review and herald
in his labors each worker is to look to
god
we are to labor as men and women who
have a living connection with god
we are to learn how to meet the people
where they are
let not such conditions exist as we
found in some places when we returned to
america
in which individual church members
instead of realizing their
responsibility look to men for guidance
and men to whom have been committed
sacred and holy trusts in carrying
forward the work failed of understanding
the value of personal responsibility
and took upon themselves the work of
ordering and dictating what their
brethren should do or should not do
these are things that god will not allow
in his work
he will put his burdens upon his burden
bearers
every individual soul has the
responsibility before god
and is not to be arbitrarily instructed
by men as to what he shall do
what he shall say and where he shall go
we are not to put confidence in the
counsel of men
and assent to all they shall say unless
we have evidence that they are under the
influence of the spirit of god
nobody has the right
to tell you
what your conscience should dictate to
you
that is the spirit of antichrist and the
papal system is antichrist
whether protestantism wishes to return
to it or not
that is their decision but the bible has
not changed
it's not only in the church
but in the workplace as well nobody
can dictate to you
what you should do
i'll take an example i don't drink
anymore
so if you require me to start drinking
again to work here
then i'm going to say sorry then i have
to make an another choice well that
happened to me when i stopped drinking
family member of mine said to me
if you no longer will drink with me then
our relationship is over yeah well
that's the choice that's a choice so you
have to stand by your choice you have to
stand by
what
the bottom line i also want to make it
quite clear
we have given information on both sides
of the story we have told no one to
vaccinate or not to vaccinate
it's just information
and some people on the one side will say
that the information on the other side
has to be debunked and vice versa
but the choice eventually lies with the
individual
here is a
quote from general conference bulletin
the plans upon which god wishes us to
work have been laid down never
should the mind of one man or the minds
of a few men
be regarded as sufficient in wisdom and
power to control the work
and say what plans shall be followed the
burden of the work in this broad field
should not rest upon two or three men
so the congregation for doctrine and
faith which is a few men dictating to
the entire body
what they should do is not in the order
of god and neither is it in the order of
god in any institution no matter what
kind
no one should lean wholly upon another's
mind
but as god's free agent each should ask
wisdom of him
when the learner depends on a large
degree upon another man's thoughts and
goes no further than to accept his plans
he sees only through that man's eyes
and is so far only an echo of the other
god willed by his own spirit work
directly through the mind he has put in
man if the man will only give him chance
to work and will recognize his dealings
with him
god designs that men shall use their
minds and consciences for themselves
he never designed that one man should
become the shadow of another and utter
only another sentiments
but this error has been coming in
amongst us that a very few
are to be mind conscience and judgment
for all god's workers
the foundation of christianity is christ
our righteousness
men are individually responsible to god
and must act as god acts upon them not
as another human mind acts upon their
mind
for if this method of indirect influence
is kept up souls cannot be impressed and
directed by the great i am
they will on the other hand have their
experience blended with another
and will be kept under a moral restraint
which allows no freedom of action or of
choice
we cannot
allow the spirit of antichrist to
dictate to us what we should do or what
we should believe
you know martin in our church even
they have come in so many diverse views
and some people are so militant for
their view
and so determined that everybody must
see it exactly as they see it
or they will describe them as
lost individuals with no chance of
salvation
if we were to adopt the right attitude
and allow
freedom of conscience
then god would be able to work with
every individual
in his labor
each worker is to look to god we are to
labor as men and women who have a living
connection with god
we were bought with a price yes
i don't belong to the pope
i don't belong to the jesuits i don't
belong to any man on this earth i have
been bought with a price yes
and the decisions that i make in my life
must be determined with through my
connection with god i can listen to the
advice of men correct i have no problem
with some someone saying in my opinion
it is safe to take this vaccine
but i have no right to say you should
take it or you are a danger to someone
else correct
in my opinion
you should not take the vaccine is the
other view
for these and these reasons
but i have no right to dictate to you
correct that you should not take the
vaccine
and this is what it is about this is
what we are talking about today and that
is where the problem
of
what is happening
is showing its red light
there is a lot of dictating telling you
this is what you should do exactly and
we have a clash of philosophies
because we have very clear directives
from god
as to how we should approach disease
stay away from drugs
is an admonition that we have
and if we want to
choose to go god's root then that is our
right
and it is the duty of everyone to
respect that
right
i think people have lost sight
of the real issue
and we need to go back
to the bible
and we can glean some information from
the spirit of prophecy now here i have
spirit of prophecy
volume 4.
and i just want to read a few passages
if i may
you may i may
it says here quite clearly
that romanism is now regarded this is
on page 308
romanism is now regarded by protestants
with far greater favor than in former
years
as we said this year
the economical
council
might just complete the work
they're waiting for the jubilee they
always wait for a jubilee it can't be
done on another day you know
there is an increasing indifference
concerning the doctrines that separate
the reformed churches from the papal
hierarchy
the opinion is gaining ground that after
all we do not differ so widely upon
vital points as have been supposed
here is an organization
that absolutely denies the atonement
and places
priests and prelates and saints
in the position of jesus christ and we
call it a christian institution
and we mingle with them
so the opinion is gaining ground that
after all we do not differ so widely
upon vital points as has been supposed
and that a little concession on our part
will bring us into a better
understanding with rome
the time was when protestants placed a
high value upon the liberty of
conscience which has been so dearly
purchased
they taught their children to abhor
potpourri
we're not abhorring
the people the individuals we abhor
the
doctrines and what they stand for
and held that to remain at peace with
rome would be disloyalty to god
but how widely different are the
sentiments now
expressed
and then it warns on the next page
let the restraints now imposed by
secular governments be removed and rome
be reinstated in a former power and they
would speedily be a revival of a tyranny
and persecution
have you seen words of that nature
absolutely
and have we seen in previous episodes
and all of that the governments that
exactly did exactly that what you've
changed they're on the same page they
have given that authority back to rome
absolutely
she states on page 382 the roman church
is far reaching in her plans and modes
of operation it's interesting to me
that she is using the right arm
the health message
to enforce compliance to her decrees
which will eventually go over to
sunday legislation when it comes to
climate change legislation which is next
on the agenda
but people are being programmed to obey
the dictates no matter what
but she is employing every device to
extend her influence and increase her
power
in preparation for a fierce and
determined conflict to regain control of
the world to re-establish persecution
and to undo all that protestantism
has done
we are there
the
i'm just to put that in other in other
words
what happens now if you don't go along
with wearing your mask or
getting the vaccine we've seen that the
articles
you are
yes and
you don't get uh all the privileges and
all of so you're actually absolutely
getting
forced to take it or otherwise the
consequences will be dire
absolutely
well there's lots that we can read here
let me read one more statement here
but god will have a people upon the
earth to maintain the bible and the
bible only
as the standard of all doctrine and the
basis of all reforms
and also the basis of my decisions
the opinions of learned men
the deductions of science
the creeds or decisions of
ecclesiastical councils
as numerous and discordant as are the
churches with which they represent
the voice of the majority
not one or all of these should be
regarded as evidence for or against any
point of religious faith
before a plane thus says the lord
in its support this is page 413
my brother
this is an issue which has religious
ramifications whether we like it or not
correct
here's another quote christ foresaw that
the undue assumption of authority
practiced by the scribes and the
pharisees would not cease with the
dispersion of the jews
he had a prophetic view of the work of
exalting human authority to rule the
conscience
which has been so terrible a curse to
the church in all ages
and his fearful denunciation of the
scribes and the pharisees and his
warnings to the people not to follow
these blind leaders were placed on
record as an admonition to future
generations
these are serious issues this is where
we are
in the stream of time
it says here on page 416 with divine
help
well let me read a little more
let me start from ignorance of god's
word is sin
when every provision has been made that
we may become wise we should day by day
study the bible diligently
weighing every thought and comparing
scripture with scripture
with divine help
we are to form our opinion for ourselves
as we are to answer for ourselves before
god
when the pope talks about the virus of
individualism he is the enemy of
everything
scriptural he is the enemy of god he is
the antichrist
our reason why many theologians have no
clearer understanding of god's word
is they close their eyes to truths which
they do not wish
to practice
so what is our bottom line
here is the guardian and it says the
world health organization warns covet 19
pandemic is not necessarily the big one
martin we've been saying all along this
is a stepping stone yep
do you still stand by that oh hundred
percent
this is not going to go away
this is going to escalate
in the culmination of prophecy no matter
what ecclesiastical body tries to
prevent it they're not going to succeed
so martin our voices
in the light of this is not the big one
we're going for that
final push
what does that mean to the voice must it
be lifted up like a trumpet or must it
go out in a whimper
must have become a loud cry
it must become a loud cry the world
needs to know where this is heading this
is the conflict with the god of heaven
great
the opinion of man as opposed to the
dictates of god
and nobody
nobody should have the right to silence
that voice of warning in the time that
we are living in
nobody has to the right
to say that we may not call the
institution
that the reformers pointed out
as the enemy of all righteousness
nobody has to right to say that
economism has reversed the situation
nothing has changed the bible is
absolutely accurate in what it is saying
and i will say one thing and i may
come as a shock to people
this pandemic has been very severe it's
been it's spread around the world
extremely quickly it has affected every
corner of this planet but this is not
necessarily the big one this virus is
very transmissible
but and it kills people and it just
deprives so many people of loved ones
but its current case fatality is
reasonably low in comparison to other
emerging diseases this is a wake-up call
we are learning now how to do things
better how to do science better how to
do logistics better how to do uh
training better how to do governance
better how to communicate better we've
developed a whole new science of
infodemology and advanced behavioral
science in this way so i think
for from our perspective
the planet is fragile
we live in an increasingly complex
global society these threats will
continue if there's one thing we need to
take from this pandemic with all of the
tragedy and loss is that we need to get
our act together we need to get ready
for something that may even be more
severe in future
you know martin that logo
with the serpent around the pole
asclepius
that serpent has more to say
than just medical things
we have to beware of that serpent
so
started off with the bang
and the bottom line is that a decision
will have to be made
and if this is just the forerunner
then the real decision
is just around the corner yes
i believe it with all my heart
and i want to encourage the viewers
to study the word of god
to study the issues carefully
prayerfully together with god
and to individually decide where we want
to stand
in terms of this issue may god help us
let's pray
heavenly father
the world is
teetering on a knife edge
that power
that has slain the saints of god over
the centuries
is rising up
to assert its power in the time that we
are living in
and lord
prophecy is fulfilling before our eyes
and we pray for individual vision wisdom
to deal
with the questions at hand
we thank you
that you are a god
that has saved us
individually
and we pray for your protection and
guidance in this issue in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again